Traduttore: Laura Comand
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Qualche tempo fa ho trovato
in un cassetto una vecchia pratica.
L'ho aperta e ho trovato un contratto
scritto da un praticante di mio nonno
con alcune sue annotazioni a penna.
L'ho confrontato con quello
che vedevo sul monitor
un contratto con tanti markup colorati
e mi sono domandato:
"Ma che cosa vuol dire
essere professionista oggi,
e come si fa a diventarlo?"
Guardate questa foto.
Vedete il professionista più anziano,
il senior, l'artigiano,
l'imprenditore di prima generazione
che, forte di una conoscenza
acquisita nel tempo, insegna a un ragazzo
più giovane, il quale è ben consapevole
di apprendere da un maestro
ed è disposto, in cambio,
a lavorare molte per ore al giorno
essendo pagato molto poco,
anche nulla, da vero praticante.
E accetta tutto ciò perché sa
che un giorno toccherà anche a lui
questo stesso onere e onore.
Ora, guardate questa foto.
Il più giovane è davanti.
È lui che comanda, insegna
a persone molto piú vecchie di lui.
Come è stato possibile tutto questo?
Nell'arco di un decennio,
grazie a quella che si può definire
una nuova scoperta del fuoco, Internet,
sembra che si sia invertito il flusso,
la direzione del trasferimento
intergenerazionale delle competenze.
Anche nel mondo delle professioni,
delle aziende,
per la prima volta nella storia,
sembra che siano i giovani
a dover insegnare ai vecchi.
Tutto questo è stato possibile,
abbiamo detto, grazie a Internet.
Internet non ha cambiato solo la nostra
concezione dello spazio e del tempo
e ha accelerato
drammaticamente le nostre vite;
Internet ha creato uno spazio
di condivisione globale, la rete,
in cui milioni di persone
hanno riversato la propria esperienza,
la propria conoscenza,
i propri saperi imparati nel tempo.
Grazie a questo, ciascuno di noi,
in maniera gratuita, in maniera immediata
può accedere a un patrimonio
di informazioni infinito
e può, senza recarsi in una biblioteca,
senza stare a bottega da qualcuno,
senza lavorare in un'azienda
o in uno studio professionale,
imparare quanto c'è di più nuovo al mondo.
Bello, no?
Secondo me non è un caso
che oggi si parli tanto di start up,
e di spazi co-working
e siano diventati un nuovo mantra.
Non è, a mio avviso, la crisi economica.
D'altra parte le nuove generazioni,
i giovani d'oggi
che senso ha che imparino,
che vadano a bottega da qualcuno
che non ha più nulla
di nuovo da insegnargli?
Sono cambiati completamente
i modelli, i parametri;
tanto vale rischiarsela da soli,
inizare qualcosa di nuovo
prendendo dalla rete quello che serve
e cercando di offrire soluzioni nuove,
senza dover lavorare gratis per altri,
magari lavorando, invece,
insieme ad altri coetanei
che hanno competenze diverse
apprese sfruttando,
ancora una volta, la rete.
Guardate io ve ne parlo,
non per sentito dire.
Quattro anni fa, proprio grazie
a un ragazzo conosciuto su Internet,
molto più giovane di me,
abbiamo creato una startup
che ha generato un software che,
a sua volta,
genera documenti legali su internet
e li genera in 10 lingue diverse
e abbiamo clienti da 50 Paesi.
Vendiamo diritto in tutto il mondo.
Bello, no?
Ma non voglio parlarvi di questo.
Voglio parlarvi sempre del trasferimento
generazionale delle competenze
e ora pensare alla generazione
non più giovane,
ma alla generazione
di chi è stato un nostro maestro.
Improvvisamente grazie a Internet,
di nuovo,
una generazione di imprenditori,
di professionisti che aveva imparato
a sua volta dai propri maestri
una certa serie di competenze
si è trovato un analfabeta 2.0.
È arrivato il processo civile telematico,
è arrivata la fatturazione elettronica,
la firma digitale, un sacco di novità
tutte insieme.
Difficile stare al passo.
E ben presto, anche lo stesso esercizio
dei diritti civili per questa generazione
diventerà complesso.
Dialogare con la pubblica amministrazione,
richiedere un certificato, persino votare,
richiederà l'uso esclusivo
di strumenti tecnologici.
Rischiamo quindi che
un'intera generazione venga estromessa.
Ma a questo punto,
vi voglio fare una domanda
perché io me la sono posta:
"Siamo sicuri che questa nuova generazione
sia autosufficiente,
non abbia bisogno di maestri?"
Abbiamo la rete, dalla quale
possiamo apprendere qualsiasi cosa
e, dall'altro lato, vi faccio una domanda:
"Vi fareste difendere da un avvocato
che ha imparato solo da banche dati
o da un medico che ha imparato
solo su Internet?"
È una domanda sempre piú attuale
e per questo ho pensato di rivolgerla
a un professionista d'eccezione
da molto tempo:
l'avvocato Marco Tullio Cicerone.
Cicerone per i suoi tempi
è stato un grande innovatore,
è stato il primo a utilizzare la scienza
retorica per vincere in giudizio,
per convincere il giudice.
È l'arte del persuadere.
Ma Cicerone è rimasto famoso
fino ai giorni d'oggi
perché è riuscito a scandagliare
nel profondo l'animo umano,
grazie proprio alla sua esperienza
come avvocato.
E, se ci pensate bene,
ciascun avvocato ha, da 2.000 anni,
sempre lo stesso cliente: un uomo.
Siamo tutti, prima di essere
professionisti imprenditori,
uomini al servizio di altri uomini.
E non è un caso, quindi, che a Stanford
nel corso di Computer Science,
siano necessari crediti
di materie umanistiche.
Lo strumento senza un fine
non ha alcun senso.
Quindi, mi domando:
"Tutto si sta evolvendo?"
I recinti delle professioni
non sono più validi
non ci sono più solo avvocati,
notai o commercialisti.
Ci sono avvocati che scrivono software,
ci sono matematici che scrivono algoritmi
per verificare la correttezza
delle decisioni dei giudici.
Ci sono ingegneri che scrivono
smart contracts,
cioè contratti autoeseguenti
attraverso la blockchain.
Un po' come con Uber o Airbnb,
tutti noi possiamo essere ogni giorno
professionisti o clienti,
albergatori o clienti,
possiamo essere maestri o allievi.
Quindi la mia domanda è: "Chi è
il professionista 3.0?" e soprattutto
torno alla domanda iniziale:
"È possibile che esista ora
una generazione autosufficiente,
che non ha più bisogno di maestri?"
Io credo che la risposta sia no.
Credo che abbiamo una cassetta degli
attrezzi molto più ampia,
molti più strumenti.
La rete è qualcosa di fondamentale,
ma solo attraverso un'alleanza
tra generazioni riusciremo a rispondere
alle esigenze di un uomo,
che anche vive di esperienza:
l'esperienza umana.
E guardate, a me piacerebbe moltissimo
conoscere le opinioni
così come mi sarebbe piaciuto parlare
con mio nonno di questi stessi temi
e forse la tecnologia
ci può dare uno strumento.
Utilizzate, per favore, questo hashtag
e scrivete le vostre opinioni.
E chi non è capace può chiedere sempre
al suo vicino più giovane.
Grazie.
(Applausi)